Festival tip number 805: There will be mud.
It's really, really beautiful from up here.
I'm gonna show you how you can take an incredible photo using the rule of thirds.
So essentially, the rule of thirds means you're putting your subject in the third of the screen.
It creates a way more dramatic sense of mood.
I know you wanna take a photo like this and put them in the entire frame,...
...but you're gonna bring it back, you're gonna use these amazing grid lines here...
...to line up their eyes.
This way I can see the bridge, and I'm gonna line the top line up with the bridge.
Now we have her in three of the boxes.
Perfect!
Let's see which one I like the best for Instagram.
These are all cute.
Oh, that is definitely the one.
Bring it in.
I think I'm gonna make this black-and-white to make it even more dramatic.
Actually, I like this black and white.
Perfect!
Rule of thirds works every time.